[Music]
Amazon CloudFront is an economical but a
dynamic content delivery network or CDN
it enables you to enhance the experience
of users accessing both static and
dynamic content of your website Amazon
CloudFront administers an association of
edge locations to store copies of
frequently accessed files in proximity
to its users for a definition edge
locations refer to the boundaries
between locations of major cloud servers
when a visitor requests the desired
content whether it is dynamic static or
streaming Amazon CloudFront makes it
available from the nearest network of
edge locations
this results in objects traveling
shorter distances thereby improving
website performance but what about files
that are not cached Amazon CloudFront
continues to maintain connection with
servers that originally host content
files so when a visitor requests content
Amazon CloudFront ensures that the
requested objects reach the visitor
immediately Amazon Cloud Front supports
users requesting data using both web
browsers and mobile devices
unlike Amazon glacier the solution is an
ideal choice to distribute the
frequently access static and dynamic
content such as videos pictures software
products and dynamic web applications
over HTTP the two key advantages of
utilizing Amazon CloudFront
are its ability to scale according to
your requirement and the flexible cost
model with the former you don't need to
take the burden of managing high priced
web servers to manage your web traffic
needs instead you can start small and
grow as the traffic to your website
increases in fact the Amazon CloudFront
service automatically managed your
traffic load without your intervention
now the latter cost model there is no
minimum monthly commitment or a fixed
term contract to dynamically deliver
content using Amazon CloudFront
in fact you are expected to pay only for
the content you deliver using its
service Hey once you become an expert in
cloud computing then subscribe to
simpler Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here